now all Ethernet cables are created
equally so how do you know which one is
right for you well here is a quick
rundown on technical and physical
differences between different Ethernet
cables and hopefully by the end of this
video you can make an educated decision
on which Ethernet cable is right for you
[Music]
welcome to higher salaries there are
five main specifications of reasoner
cables which are cat5 cat5e cat6 cat 6a
and cat 7 as the specification number
gets higher so does the speed and
megahertz of the wire cat five supports
up to 100 Mbps so honestly unless you
have fibre service this should be
sufficient for you also these are just
minimum specifications and they can
probably run higher speeds it's just not
guaranteed cat 5e or cat
and proves upon the data rate of cat 5
and brings up to 1 Gbps they both can be
up to 100 meters cat 6 and cat 6a
support up to 10 Gbps but cat 6 only
supports it up to 55 meters cat 6a is
equipment more my person is able to
improve upon that distance up to 100
meters finally cat survey is much more
of a minimal upgrade but the main
difference between extensive shielding
it is usually very difficult to find
difference in terms of data rate between
cat 6a and cat 7 as a result there
usually is no reason to spend extra
money and get cat 7 cat aid has not yet
been ratified but it's thought to bring
25 to 40 Gbps moving on those actually
have physical difference between cat5
and cat6 cables Alexander Graham Bell
invented cable twisting 1881
for uses telephone lines that run
alongside power lines he has covered
that by reducing the cable every three
to four utility poles this would reduce
interference and increase the range
booster pairs have become the basis for
all eternity bells at this point as a
result the difference between cat5 and
cat6 is number of twists per centimeter
cat 5e usually has one point five to two
twists per centimeter
while cat 6 has over two twists per
centimeter since all Ethernet cables are
twisted manufacturers you
shilling to further reduce interference
there are different types of shielding
but typically comes down to putting a
shield around each twisted pair of wire
UTP are on shield toaster peers are more
than enough for a wire that is going
from your computer to your wallet or
router usually you only want STP or
shielded twisted-pair when you are
running wiring through your walls where
there could be a lot of interference
solid and strategy Ethernet cables
actually refers to copper that run
through the wire solid cables is a
single piece of copper while stranded
cables use a series of copper wires are
twisted together family cables are
usually more flexible and more suited
whenever there is a lot of moving with
the cable for example at your desk solid
cables are much more durable and ideal
for wiring through your walls so
basically that's pretty much it as to
what all the eatment jargon is all about
so which one is right for you
well I would recommend going with at
least cat 5e nowadays is actually very
difficult to even find cat 5 - you're
pretty much forced to go to at least cat
5e for most people cat 6 or cat 6a is
the perfect choice but the cat 6a really
only being useful for super long
distance wiring and finally cat 7 is
really just not necessary you would
really only by cat 7 if you want the
newest and most updated specification
also something to keep in mind is that
if you're going to be plugging this
directly into the wall then there's no
point in buying specification as it
clearer than what runs through your
walls if you do not know what cable runs
through your house then it is probably
cat5e or cat6 cat 7 it's usually only
reserved for new bills
so here's rundown go into cat 5e if
you're on tight budget cat 6 is perfect
for most people if you want something
just a bit better than that go with cat
6a and if you want the best think about
Scott 7 and go with unshielded and
stranded if you're using your your
computer and shielded and solid if
you're running through your walls but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think
what specification do you have and would
you like an upgrade Richard comes that
down below also if you guys liked this
video and thought was helpful dimension
up alike and you can start subscribing
if you like see more
just like this one bye till then I'm
Hari I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]